So, good evening.
We will be continuing our
discussion from the last
session.
Last session was a more of an
overview session about what we
are going to discuss in the
subject and and so on.
So giving a very brief overview
and also we had a brief
discussion on the data types of
data that exist in the
organizations, how they are
related.
If we look at one specific
vendors architecture for
enterprise data and I hope
things are clear, I have heard
already from a couple of like
zipping's that they won't some
of those concepts are to be
reviewed and I'm going to do
that.
That will be the first thing I
will do, so I think it is Miss
Rashmi.
Bala is 1 and other thing I'm
not sure.
I think it is Mr Ranganathan.
So what I'll do is, so I'm going
into the slide deck for the
first session.
We have not completed the deck,
so we will anyway spend some
more time and I'm going into
first the concept of Market
Basket analysis that but that
you brought out.
So the Market Basket analysis,
uh, OK, this is the this is also
called association rule
discovery or association
analysis.
People use many terms, so let's
not worry.
But then we'll see what is the
type of analysis that we do and
what is the type of pattern that
we will discover.
So Miss Rashmi balance, so we
can talk, right?
We can talk.
I hope you will be talking and I
I can clarify, possibly because
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
just for the benefit of time, I
want to stick to a what is the
concern?
And then so I'm I think I'm at
the right slide, right?
Yes.
So here we are talking about
typical transactions.
We will just take the example
with the Market Basket only, but
though this approach can be used
to solve many problems that we
will see because in fact we will
spend considerable time on the
association rules after mid
semester.
So The thing is that association
is if we take a quick Market
OK.
Basket example.
So what we are seeing is that in
in a store, many customers are
walking in and taking something
in.
They're getting something in
their basket and walking out
with by making the payment and
walking out.
So we have observed for one
store the five customers who
have done who have worked out.
So customer one had two items in
the basket, customer four had
four items in the basket,
customer again customer five
also has four items in the
basket.
So based on what they have, we
can always think in terms of is
it possible that if a person
buys butter and bread, is it
likely that the person can buy
milk?
So so the question is that to
being, of course this is a rule
stated in the form of just a in
with the list of items, but we
need certain measures associated
with the rule to say whether
some rule is more interesting
than the other.
A Miss Rashmi Bala, are we clear
with the association rules?
Uh, you said.
Got it.
Suppose uh, instead of bread.
Uh.
Suppose someone buys some
different item, so that will be
Yes.
belongs to the market.
Backer supposed to have four
members, so the one person is by
bread, milk and other.
There's some vegetables, so they
didn't buy the bread and milk or
any dairy product.
So that is that like the rule
follow or like it will be
different.
OK, OK.
So what you are asking is
suppose that there is a family
of four members.
So one member bought something
and another member bought
something else.
Do we combine that?
Is that the question?
Yes.
OK.
Certainly it is possible.
It is always possible that we
can include because this is,
after all, a data scientist can
decide how to do it.
So can include.
See ID and the CID will be for
let's say for the transaction
one it is 1 transaction 2 it is
2, transaction 3 it is again one
because the same customer ID the
person with the same frequent
buyer card comes back and then
this is 4 and then let us say
this is 2.
So we are going to reduce this
into two groups of items or
sorry, three groups of items.
One is representing customer one
and another representing
customer two, another
representing customer 4 Mr Bala.
Does that answer your question?
Uh, yes.
So actually I need one favor.
Whatever the explaining in the
slide, if that will be uploaded
uploading canvas then that will
be easy for us.
Like we'll remember those
things.
See see.
See Mr ASMI Bala.
I'll tell you one thing, when we
when the session is but right
now the session is getting
recorded and also the transcript
is being created and sometimes
the transcript sounds very funny
because it distorts it doesn't.
It doesn't make very good
recognition of speech, but many
things it catches.
So in spite of its mistakes, you
should still be able to capture
our discussion, so that is all
there for you to watch at your
convenience.
And now what exactly are you
looking for?
What more do you want?
Come and take the slide.
So it is like instead of
watching the video of suppose
after watching the videos, if
we'll go through the document,
whatever you say it if that is
like the some example will be
there.
So it will like it will be more
clarified the concept and will
be more clear.
OK, Miss Rashmi, Bella, you are
saying the slide deck is the
slide deck going to be
available?
Yes, whatever you are explaining
in the slide, if that concept
will be there in the slide,
whatever uploading canvas.
You know, so, so, so you are
saying are you looking for
Hey.
slight deck or you're looking
for the annotated slide deck?
But yeah, whatever you are
explaining in the class.
I never did a slide deck and it
did it.
No, no, no, no.
With the.
I thought.
Please, I guess, he says
annotated.
So she wants and united.
It.
He means another.
Yeah, she wants senator that.
OK, she's looking for
annotations.
So you already looked at the
slide deck for slide deck one,
right?
You already got the first slide
deck.
It is already posted in canvas
and you looked at it so.
Right. So.
No, when no.
Whatever the examples you are
explaining in the class that
examples are not available on
that slide.
So if that will be there, then
it will be easier for us to
I don't know which which is.
catch.
Is it certainly certainly that
example if it is not covered in
the slide, maybe that would have
that is some.
Is there something that you
remember?
Because this is, this is pretty
much what I have put is
sufficient concept to understand
association rule.
So if really it is the
annotations you're considering
because the annotations increase
significantly the size, but then
yeah, fine.
If you are really looking for
annotations, yeah, fine.
We can make dinner, take a
slightly cable, but I I don't
know what is the.
What is that example that we
missed out?
But the the the banking example,
whatever they explained earlier
in the first class that is not
available.
Yeah.
Yeah, but then the yeah.
So if something of that is
missed out, you can always go to
the video recording and look at
the exact 2 minutes of that
video.
What?
What was discussed right?
I do not think that the slide
doesn't permit me to write too
much, so I'll write only limited
thing.
In any case, in the example
banking example, so yeah, there
is nothing to write, so I was
only telling that in bank they
can always Group their customers
in some way or Group the product
in second week.
Possibly that kind of example,
right?
They yeah, because of that, I
like not be able to go.
The catch the sequential concept
so.
OK, OK.
So the banking, so we were
explaining the idea of
classification and clustering.
So is that clear to you?
You understood what is
classification and what is
clustering.
Umm, actually The thing is that
that's the reason I.
No, Mr Mr Rashmi.
Bala, don't hesitate to say not
understood, because after all I
you are you are registered for
the program to learn.
No, no, I.
No, no, I understood the price
overall concept like the Group
So what is the problem?
of Things and whatever the like.
And the Group, whatever we are
doing, the supposed Group
example.
So I understood the concept, but
somehow I maybe I need to go
through again so that that's the
reason.
It's see that is something we
do.
We expect that you do revise the
thing in the.
In fact, some people put it
explicitly in handout and in our
handout it may have not have
been put, but whenever we say
that there are 32 hours of
interaction, we expect that for
after every two hours you spend
at least six hours in exploring
the content further.
So that may not be just revising
or listening to the same
recording, but it may be for
some time.
We went to listen to the
recording but further exploring,
but in any case I'm more than
happy to go back to the slide.
If you say supervised machine
learn in classification is not
understood.
OK, I don't I I I can go back.
Do you want me to go back there?
Yeah.
If when I least like fine.
Ah, OK, OK.
And I think you also had a
question about the sequential
patterns, is that correct?
Yes, yes.
OK.
So let me finish also
association you understood the
patterns that we are looking at
are combinatorial.
Yes.
So that is at one day or at one
point of time.
What are all the items that the
family or the buyer is buying?
Uh, it is.
So this is you can you can
clearly make out it is
combinatorial.
So we are not looking at any
sequence, so it doesn't mean
that it so, but then there are
many problems where the sequence
is important.
So one very simple example that
all of us can relate to is that
suppose that somebody's having a
scooty or scooter or motorcycle,
so you know that you buy the
scooter and then after buying
the scooter they say that after
six months you have to come back
for service.
Depending on the make, it may
make slightly different and then
when they do the servicing they
change the engine oil.
So clearly they're saying that
if you buy a scooter today after
six months, you have to buy a
liter of engine oil.
So that is a sequential pattern.
Is that clear?
It is also has some element of
Market Basket, but it also has a
time lag between the two and
there are many other events
which can be explained using the
sequential pattern.
I'm Mr ASMI.
Bala is that sequential and
combinatorial is clear, right?
Yeah, I.
Yes, yes.
OK, OK, so now now I will.
I I'm not very sure whether you
want really help with the
clustering and classification.
If so, if there is a some
requirement we can spend 5
minutes that is not a problem
from my side but but then
otherwise I would like to move
as far as possible.
So let me somebody, somebody has
raised the hand also please
speak other person.
Somebody raised their hand in
between.
OK.
If there is no question, OK, let
me see if there is anything in
the chat box.
OK. Ohh.
Alright.
OK, no problem.
You know what I think of cycle
life?
I think of it.
Umm.
I you know what I think the
cycle lies.
I think our cycle life and
electric sports bike and and a
sports bike electric with gears.
I think over my cycle like that.
Yeah, electrical beginner.
Is this question what is this?
I I think maybe.
Ohh Charles Bob I I do not know.
No, no, no, I see.
Are you talking to me?
What is this question or doubt?
Why did you stop?
I I think maybe that person is
talking to someone else.
OK, so uh, so that's actually
the reason why sometimes we keep
the whole session on mute, but
OK no problem.
And will the PPT for today's
session be uploaded here, here
and means a canvas right in the
canvas, the same place where we
uploaded the first session
slides.
So we will also upload the
second session, so if I remember
I'll save it with the annotation
and then upload it.
OK, so because the annotation is
actually, I increase the
significantly the size and and
you know, you know if it is
shared with 100 people, it's
obviously it is increasing the
IT has a more byte footprint,
but OK, that's that any any
other question from anyone?
Alright, we'll proceed further.
Uh, sorry.
In the sequential pattern
Discovery, if the event is going
to occur occur in the patterns,
so it means there is some
dependency in the previous.
I mean, I mean, prior to this
discovering pattern, right,
that's what that's.
Uh, OK, OK.
OK, let me let me go back and
sequential is actually little
more tricky than that.
I just want to skip it, but then
yes, go ahead.
Go ahead.
Since you brought it up.
Yeah, let us let us let us talk.
So what is the?
What is the question, either
with one of these slides, right?
Hmm.
Yeah, 38 slides.
So there even the timing
constant, everything have been
mentioned.
Yes, yes.
So if D&E for example Dey
that combination is giving that
that is an event occurred.
So that event occurrence is
having a dependency on C or a B,
Hmm.
Yeah.
right?
So that's the that's the
original concept of sequential
pattern means am I right?
Ah, see.
See in fact, the sequential
patterns are studied for many
regions, not just one region.
One of the reasons why people
study the sequential pattern is
OK.
study of the gene sequencing.
So in gene sequencing, the point
is that offers now know and
claim that yes, it is the genes
that decide so many things about
the people.
But then I hope if some of you I
I do not know if you work, but
you know that the gene sequence
is not a very single byte or
it's it is a very very long
sequence and then to map certain
part to the certain
characteristics is not so easy.
And then also finding a pattern
which is for example, two
creatures are having similarity
and you got the gene sequence
for both of them.
So now if you want to find
similarity then again it when
the gene sequence is suppose
it's running into millions of
bits.
So you can see that the problem
is not so easy.
So you need to know what is
occurring after what and what is
the length of the same sequence
that is repeating and is it
possible that this sequence is
impacting certain
characteristic?
Mr Ranganathan, have I clarified
it a little bit because the
Yeah.
problem is a lot more complex
than what we are doing is we are
trying to explain it very simply
saying that yes, we one simplest
sequential problem is that
suppose you buy today
introduction to data science,
the bookshop owner can be
assured that tomorrow you're
going to buy a book on
deeplearning.
So we can possibly simplify that
as a as the nature of the
problem, but the nature of the
problem in different context can
take different approach styles.
So in that case it is not really
that time sequencing that we are
talking about.
We are talking about one
occurring after the other, and
similarly suppose that you are
looking at the web clicks to.
There are people who analyze the
pattern of usage and then what
is bringing the business and so
many things.
So the sequence of web clicks
become important.
And do you want to consider only
the previous click or previous
five clicks are what?
How many number of clicks and
then so again the intention is
that you find a pattern but then
the definition for a pattern
itself you don't want me to
freeze it.
So there can be various
definitions for patterns, but
then the patterns that we set is
a broad category.
When we set classification
association clustering and
anomaly or sequential so and
within the association, a
combinatorial or sequential,
it's a very broad
categorization, but there are
scores of algorithms for each
type of problem, and then each
each one has its own strength,
weakness and application.
Are we In Sync?
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
All right.
So we were when we closed the
last session, we were discussing
about the processes for data
science.
So we look first at the, the
this we had already studied we
this is just an example flying
the software engineering and we
know that data science is very
closely related to the computer
science and then software
engineering is what many of the
computing professionals do so.
So we'll look at the the process
that is followed and it has a
significant impact on what what
is the way the data science
tasks are done then what we had
seen is that the question
requirement of analysis and
design, they're not going away
anywhere.
But then nomenclature that you
need to do is changing and then
in machine learning you are not
doing a design but you are
trying to create a model and so
so it's again the model becomes
with supervised machine learning
and unsupervised machine
learning.
The concept model has slightly
different, so let's just take it
that, OK, so we are trying to
build a model.
So the model may have some
discovery element within it and
then that is what we are trying
to do.
So.
So what what we know for sure is
that software engineering is
that requirements requirements
are clear, right?
So analysis clarifies
requirements.
Requirements.
And design and construction
implement the requirements.
So it's as simple as that.
So we have a problem and we have
a solution.
Analysis recognizes the problem
and design and constructions
finds the solution, but now in
data science we have a tricky
situation.
So what we are saying is that
the problem.
Yes, the problem is more like we
want to find a pattern, so that
is really does a pattern exist
and then 2 for that we need to
identify what is the type of the
data that can help.
So possibly that that starts the
solution cycle, so identifying
the necessary data and then
within the data we need to find
the model that will express the
patterns within the data.
So there.
So the point is that in spite of
the fact focus that every
machine learning book says that
yes, you are creating a model
from the data.
So we need to understand that
there is an algorithm and we
will look at some algorithms
whereby we create a model.
So the construction of the
algorithm itself requires some
coding, and today we may not do
a lot of coding because many of
those algorithms have been
already incorporated into the
library.
So either the Python library or
libraries, so if you go and see
that the Python because there
are so many enthusiastic open
source community members who
have implemented so all you need
to do is to just invoke those
algorithms and get the results.
But then the algorithm exists
and is implemented, and that is
pretty much like a development,
because you're writing a code
which is which has a logic
within, and that algorithm is
representing that logic.
So once that is done, what you
see is a pattern which is
possibly expressing the kind of
right the the relations within
the data or or the understanding
or insights that you gather from
the data.
So I hope that clarifies how the
data science process is
different from software
engineering process and we have
looked at the crisp DM
framework.
So apparently that is one of the
more popular frameworks that is
used for data science.
And then we have looked at the
details of the phases and tasks
and we have also looked at the
booklet that is published by
these people in the data Science
Process Alliance Group and the
URL is in front of you.
And we looked at it.
So you can explore it further
and if there is further
discussion is required, we can
do this and this part.
I don't think we have reached in
the last class, so this is the
there are alternate.
Two crisp DM.
Just be a bit that these are not
very, very different from that,
but they are trying to present
the steps in a slightly
different way and they're trying
to differentiate themselves
through some elements, but not
really not really a significant
because and also many times they
also go for a new nomenclature
that puts us into into the
problem that what is really how
are they significantly
different.
But then be be be busy.
You can say that it's an
alternate process which is again
working with the the data in a
particular sequence.
Particularly, they focus is more
on big data, but then finding
the patterns and big data.
In fact, we know that we are
looking for patterns because
there is so much data for which
the querying is not an option,
not a possibility.
So only thing is that we can
look for patterns so so the big
data is a very good example
where doing a query is not a not
a very comfortable proposition,
but discovering patterns is.
And then SEMA is proposed by CS,
so they are one of the popular
tools in the data science and
they talk in terms of data
science tasks, in terms of their
sampling, exploring, then
preprocessing the data and then
modeling the data and then
assessing the results.
And again, they talk in terms of
iteration after the model is
assessed, you go back and then
start repeating the process.
Uh, by making some changes?
And then there is a SM AM, which
is proposed by one group.
Which clients itself as data
science association.
So here we are talking about a
cycle based the use case and
then we are talking about gather
requirements gathering and then
performing some experiments and
then working with the proof of
value return on investment, then
operationalization.
So this is a.
This is again not very much
different and you can see that
they have a slightly different
nomenclature.
Yeah, someone has a question.
Someone has a question for me?
No question.
I I'm assuming no question, so
let me proceed further.
And then finally, there are new
terms that are coming up.
So so we need to understand why
and what for these terms have
come up and what is it that the
people are trying to convey.
So the two terms that we talk
about are data OPS and ML OPS.
Is everybody familiar with the
DevOps?
People are familiar with DevOps,
right?
Yes, OK.
OK, Mr Gotta pass form.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, creating a pipeline.
Yes, it's.
So what exactly is really the
concept behind it?
What is it that why they need to
bring in a new nomenclature?
Maybe we can.
The main idea is to automate the
entire SDLC cycle right from you
know the elopement or and
testing part of it and
deployment.
All those gets into a pipeline.
OK.
Yes.
OK.
No problem, no problem.
Adds adds.
You are answering so.
So what is the meaning of
automation so so really because
one thing when we started
software development started as
a profession, they said we are
trying to automate the process.
But now here we are saying that
we are automating something.
Pick to market.
What is that?
Click to market.
Elimination of manual efforts.
Greek to market?
And the benefit is quick to
market, but the idea behind is
that minimum human intervention,
the flow should go, you know.
The continuous integration and
deployment.
And yeah, you continuous
process.
OK, alright.
Continuous integration and
different.
OK.
Yeah. Alright.
So I'm hitting a the NS.
Two other terms which are
popularly used in the context of
DevOps.
So.
So the point is that so DevOps
actually is a more offshoot.
I see.
If my understanding of whatever
I observed in the industry is
clear so till 19 till 2000,
possibly nobody ever thought
that they need to because the
software itself is meant to
automate a process.
So that is a business process.
We are auto then then the what?
The some movement that started
that is called Azle development.
Umm.
So these people have brought in
several concepts, saying that
working software is more
important than documentation and
people are more important than
processes.
And whatnot.
So it was like they started with
some manifesto and and then many
people hung on to it because my
not if it is reducing the work
and giving a quick delivery, why
not go for it?
And so in the asile, the idea is
that the delivery is always very
small increments many, many
increments.
So you start delivering after
every few weeks.
So once you have to deliver
after every few weeks, so the
integration itself has to happen
every because previously the
delivery he used to be more in a
batch mode that is after three
months or six months you make a
delivery.
But here we are talking about a
delivery of every week or every
two weeks or three weeks.
So what that means is that as
the new delivery comes, they
need a mechanism to do an
integration.
So so it is more like the IT is
the rapid cycles that are
creating then need saying that
OK let's have some level of
automation so that we don't need
to worry as long as soon as they
bring in the code.
So there is an automated process
to absorb that into the
production software.
Uh, so I hope all of us are In
Sync.
Or am I telling something some
different story than you?
People want to tell it's the
same story, right?
Yeah.
The yes.
Yep.
OK, because in fact the story is
interesting word there is there
was a time when people used to
say that we gather requirements,
but then asile people said that
we'll gather stories.
So.
So whatever impossibly they hear
when they when they use the word
stories, probably that gives
them something which the
requirements don't give so much.
Like, OK, why not go for a new
terminology?
So OK, so the ML OPS and data
OPS are obviously these are the
offshoots that when software
development has DevOps, why the
machine learning should lag
behind and say that we are doing
work in a batch mode, uh, So
what they started doing is to
bring in some nomenclature and
bringing in some some things
that differentiate.
So for example we the data
preprocessing is a significant
activity in many of the data
science projects.
So as they do this, they can
possibly integrate and create
the data pipelines.
And the possibly that will that
will be continuous basis.
So that is as in as soon as they
discover a new data source or a
new data mode, or I will say a
new data source or a new data
format, or a new data structure.
You need to have a mechanism to
incorporate that in a rapid
manner, so this is what seems to
be the intent of data OPS.
So are there any data OPS
experts?
So somebody who is working and
they refer to within their
organization what they call as a
data OPS.
OK, so fine, fine.
So this is a nomenclature and
what we are saying is that
bringing in automation into the
data pipelines.
So this is this is one way in
which this picture is not really
telling too much.
All we are saying is that there
are several activities that need
to happen within the data
pipeline.
So why not include the
automation, alerts, dashboards
etcetera?
So thereby what we are having,
what we are having is that the
process is getting more smooth
and and then possibly the cycle
time can also improve.
And now we will look at another
term that is that was brought up
which is ML OPS.
So the DevOps as some of you
have already pointed out, deals
with two terms.
One needs continuous
integration.
And continuous deployment or
continuous delivery.
OK.
Now, now the question is that ML
systems also we want the same
thing.
Why not?
Why not integrate the new data
sources or et cetera continuous
basis and build the model and
then give a incremental or a new
model on a continuous basis?
So what the recognized is that a
new word that is required is
that ML OPS requires continuous
training.
So that is adds new data or new
formats or new structures that
come in.
So we need to validate that the
training that is adequate or a
retraining is required for the
models because the models are
constructed by training on the
data.
And this this two.
OK, this ML OPS so we are
looking at the Google Cloud page
where they're talking about ML
OPS.
So.
So they're talking about.
I do not know how clear this
picture is.
But I thought it doesn't make
sense for me.
It's clear we can read, yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
So thank you for that.
So all we are saying is you can
see that what they are talking
about, they are talking about
automated pipeline and saying
that yes, so as the data comes
in, they're doing doing all
automation and then maintaining
a model registry and then
maintaining the other activity
other things like the
performance and.
So this is representing the
continuous training that we're
talking about.
So and then the the orchestrated
experiment is to validate
whether the model still works
well.
So this URL is given in the
slide deck.
So so some of you who are
interested in further
exploration can study.
I think this is a.
There are several contents that
Google presents as what they
think is the email or ML OPS.
Sir, when we say ML basically or
data offs it's a converting the
All right, yes.
unstructured data in a
structure.
Is it the right statement? No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, it is
not really neat.
Receipt see the data
transformation is always part of
the data pipeline, but then not
necessarily because it is
unstructured data.
Structured data.
For example, you are getting
data from two sources where
which is in American source.
That puts date in mmddyy format
and something is an Indian
source with they put the data
and ddmmyyyy format so that is
still part of the data pipeline
so that needs to be automated
send integrated.
Having is that clear, both are
structured data, so there is
nothing like it has to be
unstructured to structure.
But it is also possible that it
is.
It is.
The data can be of wide
varieties.
Are we In Sync?
Yes.
So basically means in in this
data OPS we are making kind of a
patterns within a.
This process is itself or like
method to this.
Yes, yes.
See see.
It is pretty much the same thing
like what happens in DevOps is
that they use several tools so
that the integration and
deployment they all become very
rapid cycles.
So all we are saying is that we
are encouraging saying that in
the even the data because the
data science projects are very
intensive and they're critically
dependent on data.
So you may get data sources from
multiple places, so you need to
have a automation so that the
data OPS will be smooth so they
when you do the OPS you for
example you are getting a new
data source that is having a
different format.
There we go.
You need to promptly recognize
that and then make the necessary
Action.
change and and enable the
integration.
Got it, Sir.
Thank you.
So probably that OPS part we we
used to apply before the
development phase in, in data
science, is it something like
Uh, see the yes.
that because like?
Go ahead.
Go ahead, Mr Devendra. Yeah.
So OK, just type like like
currently if in without not in
the world of data science.
So we used to automate the part
of like continuous deployment
and the integration along with
certain validations of the code
and quality what we use to keep
in our day-to-day SDLC
lifecycle.
So it is like after a
development these are automation
suites run over the pipeline.
So in the data science field, is
it something like when we want
to operate something over the
data.
So we went over the source as
well.
We used to apply the pipelines
and we used to like in build up
the pipeline for the source as
well and after the development
then we again have that
automation pipeline for the rest
of the life cycle that we want
to apply over that development.
So is it something like that?
I, through Mr Devendra, I think
that is what I think we are
talking.
I I'm just.
The house is open.
I mean, somebody wants to bring
in anything, any critical
observation of the question or
the points that are made,
because I think they pretty much
the similar thing that we are
talking about, we are talking
about rapid delivery and that is
possible through the automation
and we need to identify the
right kind of automation that we
can do in data science pipeline.
I don't know.
So is that.
Is there something that?
I just wanted to validate my.
I I think I think that is what I
think what you need is a.
Understanding.
What you need is consistent with
what we are talking.
So anyone observed any any
variation or anything?
OK.
OK, so I think we are In Sync.
I think we are In Sync alright,
so So what?
OK.
Uh.
We yes. Yes.
Mr Devendra, you want to say
something.
No, no, nothing.
So thank you.
OK.
OK, sorry.
No, I have a question here.
So you're talking about the
patterns, right or or really
calling the different patterns
as a model or is something
models so different with
patterns?
And now we are.
We are really talking about see,
see the finally.
The point is, when we say the
pattern.
So I think you may be present in
the previous session.
We have found one pattern saying
that the the young people are
likely to buy a particular color
and elderly people are likely to
buy a different color of car,
right?
Yeah.
Mr Mr captain, what are you
dating?
Blue and Gray.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Blue and green?
Yeah, I I recall that.
Yeah.
You, you, you would you got
that.
OK, so now now what do you think
it is called as?
Do you think it is a pattern or
it is a?
See, the model is more
formalized term, but the pattern
is what you are likely to use
this right in in a day to day
world in day-to-day
conversation.
I think you will rather say that
there is a pattern that you you
Pat and yeah.
can you can say that OK the the
the factory workers tend to vote
for a certain political party
and agricultural level work work
for another party.
So you say that is a pattern,
right?
So and so these are patterns,
but then you can express them as
a formal way in the form of a
rule or informally.
Some other structures.
Yeah, you will rather call that
as a model so that you
discovered by running some
algorithms on the data.
God. OK.
That I have a question in in the
ML OPS context, we are saying
Yes.
continuous training.
How do we visualize that what's
happening?
See, The thing is that, uh,
visualizing a continuous is
always a problem, because there
is nothing like it is really
continuous.
But then we don't want it
delayed.
So that is that is what the mood
is is more important. So.
So what I see is the they put it
is and in fact some of.
Are you familiar with DevOps?
I am.
You are familiar with, so can
you tell me some tools that are
used in DevOps?
If you're familiar, if you're
not so familiar, that's also OK.
So.
Uh.
I'm sorry.
And then some tools which are
meant for doing the version
control and some tools for
automation building and some so
something to manage the
container.
See, my point is that So what
are those tools really there
for?
So whenever they notice a
change, so they essentially tool
means that will trigger itself
and do something more, or
otherwise you just do a, trigger
it and then it is going to.
So it is really when people are
talking about this continuous,
what they're saying is that to
have some automation in place.
So what level of automation is
now?
It is becomes a more
philosophical question.
So can you say it is continuous
now?
I don't know whether I can say
it is continuous.
But then it is certainly a rapid
cycle.
That is, that all of us agree,
right?
Because there is a difference
between rapid cycle and
continuous.
So so continuous is if you are
unable to visualize continuous,
it's a.
It's yes, that is because the
continuous is not really like
the way health never stops going
around the sun.
No, maybe not.
Maybe not, maybe, but then
something rapid cycle itself is
moving towards continuous
integration.
Or or whenever there is some
process happens.
So so you create a bad job or
some or some job which gets
automatically triggered some
some level of automation.
And Mr Santosh army in Singh.
And I thank you, Sir. Yes.
OK, alright.
And so, yeah, So what exactly
is?
Yeah.
I just had a small.
Yeah.
What? What?
How would we differentiate that
that OPS and envelopes?
I mean, even in the diagram.
And then figuration seems to be
very tightly in it in that ML
OPS thing, right?
OK.
Mr Kapil, gargle.
If I repeat your question, what
is the difference really between
data OPS and ML OPS?
Is that correct?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, so data OPS is only dealing
with the data and ML OPS is also
No.
dealing with the models for the
simple reason that machine
learning is all about building
the models from the data.
Yeah, exactly my point.
So even data OPS will end up
providing information results,
right?
So what machine learning is?
To see.
OK, OK, so now now the question
is that why why K in the data
OPS it is?
So why these two different
things?
You. Yeah.
Why these two different things?
Why and why not this one? Yeah.
You know you can see that in
data OPS when they're talking
about this, they're looking at
many data sources that have to
pass through the pipeline and
result.
I hope, Mr Kapil, you are able
to see the diagram right.
Yes.
Yeah.
Yes, like.
So this is a.
This is a reasonable diagram to
represent the data pipeline
right?
Many data sources and which are
trying to reach many
destinations and then there is
some processing that is going on
But I.
in between is that fine.
Yep, Yep. Sure.
OK, so now let us go to what
Google offers ads ML pipeline.
So in ML pipeline you can see
that the model training model,
evaluation model validation,
right?
OK.
So that is what is making it a
little more than data OPS.
So that is why they're calling.
They may be calling it as mail
OPS.
So to say in some other words,
we say that the consolidated
information from data OPS is
being consumed in analogs.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So data OPS is also there.
So The thing is that in ML OPS
the they are thinking in terms
of models.
They're focus more on models.
So is the model really the
continuous training so that is
new data is coming and has it
been trained and and maybe
whatever is the implications
with incorporating the new data
for training?
OK, OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, got it.
So ML OPS is basically focusing
on the application modeling of
the data.
That is right.
So finally, the model that is
going to help in the decision
Thank you.
making or or recognizing the
patterns in the data.
That.
So that is what really they're
talking.
Yeah.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Alright, so OK, so we will
proceed.
This is this completes the
discussion on on the processes
and what we will do is we will
start the discussion on data.
Sorry to interrupt, Sir.
I just shared a small question.
Yes.
So, uh, so from a software
engineering point of view, we
are normally make a code change
when we have to basically add
some new feature or we or we
want to resolve some bugs.
So from an ML OPS point of view,
is there any?
I mean, I mean, how is it
decided that the model needs to
be retrained?
OK, now let us look at it this
way.
So typically in in model is a
outcome of, uh, of analysis of
the data.
So you analyze the data
significantly and then you are
going to out output a model.
So for example, data that we
talked about is a simplest
possible data that we talked
about right at the beginning of
the classes that I have got, the
age of the customer and the
color of the car that they're
buying.
So now we created a model saying
that OK, so based on this age
Great.
cut off, I think that the more
likely I can create a a
approximate rule with the
reasonable accuracy that if the
person is below 36 years of age,
that person will take a red car
with him and the person has a
more than 36 of years away.
That person will take a blue car
with you.
So.
So The thing is that there is a
model and then that is based on
some data.
So now suppose that there is a
data is continuously coming in.
So what will happen?
Umm, we will have more.
I mean, probably the inference
might change later on.
Absolutely.
Is it not right?
So at least if not changes, but
at least we have to be cautious
that it does not change, right?
Right.
So so there is something that we
need to do with the model,
because this model has not come
out of really a divine truth.
So we had got some data and then
we have drawn, we discovered a
pattern from that, nothing more.
OK, OK.
So, uh, I mean for the new data
that that comes in, we are we do
not know the the actual
prediction for iterate.
So how do we know that our model
is actually incorrect?
It's me.
See the see the question.
Yeah, yeah.
The question is in and in fact
it's a.
It's an interesting question.
Maybe.
Maybe we can.
We can have a discussion for
again a few minutes.
Uh, so.
So the point is, let's say I
think all of us know some real
problem that banks face for a
long time, which is a non
performing assets, right, right.
Right.
So what is that?
Is a non performing asset.
I I hope just maybe if you say
maybe I think people will be
more comfortable.
It's somebody any any person
with some banking knowledge.
Some the money which?
I think it's gonna company takes
a loan but doesn't probably
It's in that it's not not adding
up to the property.
return it.
OK.
Yeah, Mr Devendra is trying to
say something.
Maybe.
Just can you give him?
Yeah.
Mr Devendra, go ahead.
Or maybe it's something which is
not add up in the profit margin
that business probably that.
OK.
OK.
No, no.
Let me put it this way.
So it is generally what they
refer to is that they give a
loan and then the loan is not
paid in time or the installments
are not paid in time.
So and there are circuit second
criteria based on which they say
it is a non performing asset.
So now that means it is a loss
to the bank.
Bad loans, basically.
You know it is a bad loans
didn't, yeah.
Uh.
In bad loans, right that that
is, that is what is mostly the
nonperforming assets, right?
OK.
OK, so now the question is that
what is the loan approval
process in the Bank, so Luna
approval process is really a
classification problem which
they may do it in their own way.
But some of the modern banks I
will not.
Not at all.
Be surprised if they're
significantly dependent on
seeing it loan application.
They're going to take all the
100 attributes that are there in
the loan application and then
they're going to feed it to the
machine and then machine is also
going to say, is it likely to be
repaid or not.
So so now now the question is
the.
So the point is that there is a
model and even before this
machine learning coming to the
play, what was happening before.
So suppose that machine learning
was not there, so loan approval
is there.
Suppose it is a large loan.
They will say that we need to
get an approval from a senior
manager if it is a 10,000 loan,
they may say that OK, the lower
level executive can grant it.
So what is really the situation
that's happening?
The risk.
Yeah, the risk is a element.
And.
But then what they are saying is
that the IT is possible that the
senior manager has a better
judgment.
Do you agree?
Yep.
The consequence is risk, but
then they are saying that it is
senior manager because possibly
they think he knows the IT
better.
Do you agree or you don't?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Well, we agreed.
OK, very good.
OK, so now now what is the basis
for that person's judgment?
Experience.
Absolutely right.
He would speak.
What cases?
Right.
Mr Souder, it is experience.
But what is experience?
Uh.
Puristic data.
Processing.
Processing similar situation
many times in different context.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
So the point is that the senior
manager has already given 10,000
loans and knows that out of them
9500 are doing fine and 500 are
not doing fine and possibly
thought about why those 500 are
not doing fine right?
Do you agree or not?
Are you?
It's an experience based on the
huge amount of historical data.
Agreed, right.
So that is what I think I was
trying to put the numbers.
Yeah, absolutely.
You're right, Mr Praneel.
Right, right.
So everybody's In Sync that the
the and now, now let us say what
is that experience?
So when there are thousand,
10,000 times, he has sanctioned
the loan.
So that means that that person
has processed 10,000 records, is
that correct?
Is that correct or not?
Right, yes, right.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
10,000 records.
So instead of that person
running through his brain in
algorithm based on the 10,000
records, can we write an
algorithm that will take these
10,000 records and is going to
create a model that is going to
be used?
Is it possible?
Yes, yes.
At least data scientists should
think that it should be
possible, right?
Is it not so?
With, with, with some caution
because we are saying intuition
Otherwise we are in trouble yet.
is equal to 100% in algorithm.
No, no, just, no, no.
Is it?
Then in that case, Mr Santosh,
let me let me put one thing
back.
So.
So in that case, why is it that
when the same manager who has
given 100 loans and is getting
repaid, then another five loans
that manager has given and they
failed because previously also
they were when the NPS were
there, it is not that they were
not doing due diligence they
were doing due diligence and
still some of the loans were cut
becoming NPS and even today some
loans are becoming NPS maybe the
percentage you know the reissues
Yeah.
can be different.
So what can be the region?
Yeah, humans cannot be come and
now.
No, no, it is it.
The problem is it with the
humans and the problem is with
the machine.
Also, the machine also cannot
predict you with 100% accuracy.
It's.
And humans also don't have that
perfect judgment.
Parameters.
Thank you very much.
Maybe some of the parameters
it's it's.
The outliers.
Mr Manoj, rest in.
You need to be clear.
I think you are trying to say
something.
I'm not able to understand can
you repeat?
Yeah.
So the parameters and the
weightage for that parameter.
For example, like if he's taking
home loan, whether he's buying
an city area or village area
kind of right.
Mr Mr Sebastian, my question
will be that do you think that
the bank appointed as a senior
loan general manager, somebody
who doesn't know that?
We basically we cannot remember
everything from our past, right,
so.
Going through each and every
parameters again, it is a time
taking process.
So so now, now. OK.
OK.
Then in that case, do we have a
solution or we only have a
problem?
We have a solution but with
certain degree of and tolerance
OK.
for failure.
Yeah.
OK, OK alright.
So I think we are there.
I think I think what you said is
reasonable.
So whether you go for humans or
whether you go for machine, in
fact, in both these cases there
is something machine has some
superiority in the sense that it
will have a no no letter Z or no
possibility of being biased or
in some sense bias can be there.
Actually, we will talk about
that sometime later, but then
some level of you know what how
the machine behaves and you also
know how the human intelligence
works.
So in both these cases, there is
no perfection.
But then but then yes, we try.
We try to use.
Both are.
We are we.
I think what we started with
about the models and
approximations is that all clear
or now we are.
We are saying that we may not
have a perfect model.
Even yesterday, we did not
possibly have perfect model, and
even tomorrow we may not have.
So are we fine with that or
still some doubts?
OK, so our intent is most
probably to improve, but then it
doesn't mean that the what more
whatever model that existed was
perfect.
And so in that sense, the
process is about continuously
keep looking at evaluating it
and how continuous.
Again, I I leave that word aside
because continuous again, you
start questioning many things
and really there isn't answer
really anywhere.
Even in the DevOps, I don't
think it is what they say is a
continuous in the sense that
nonstop it is something
something close to that.
Alright.
So we'll proceed further and
maybe I think we are, we are
almost one hour.
So do we take 5 minute break now
and then we'll start discussion
about the data.
Yes, Sir.
OK, let's get restarted.
And what we do is that we
discuss about aspects of data,
alright.
So one of the things is that
when we you may be working many
of you may be working with
databases umm which is which
most of the business data is
stored.
So you would have heard about
the data types.
So what is the data type that
you look at such as integer?
Float and then with a specific
accuracy.
So with the number of decimal
places and then you may be
having the Webcat.
And possibly BLOB or you may be
having various data types that
if the database supports
different databases, have
different data types.
So what is the intent of all
this?
So these are really talking
about size and interpretation.
This is really a metadata about
the data.
So what we are saying is that
when we are getting so much of
data.
Which is all continuous sequence
of bits.
We need an ability to identify
saying that, OK, this part is
representing the uh, something
it is representing possibly the
the designation.
So which may be a flag with the
certain values that need to be
so.
So the point is we need a way to
interpret the data.
So for that reason, databases
typically have the database data
types, and then based on that
the size is decided and then the
contents are extracted.
So now when it comes to the data
science dance, it was little
differently because we are not
so much concerned about really
the.
Of course, we need to read the
data, so we need to know that.
But then in a data science task,
it is not really the integer and
float that is going to make a
difference.
Because when we are trying to
find a patterns that are within
the data.
So what is really making a
difference to us?
Eat certain characteristics.
So for example, when we say it
is a, the one of the data types
that we are going to come into
is so.
So the way in which we can make
a comparison so one of the
things that we need to be able
to do is that how we compare.
So it is possible that the float
and integer will have the same
method of comparison.
So we are not really so much
concerned whether it's a float
or integer.
So that is important when
somebody is managing the storage
of the data, but not for the
data science process.
So we are talking about looking
at the data and from a certain
perspective which enables us to
discover the patterns or build
the model.
So now let us see how do we look
at the data.
So here I think it requests no
explanation, so these are the
data objects.
You can take them as records if
you want or you call them as
data objects or data tuples or
instances or whatever you want
to call this, and then each one
is having the multiple
attributes and each of the
attributes has set him value and
then we can have certain
attribute which is like an
example is an eye color of a
person or a temperature.
So we know that that value value
can have in meaning and then
that meaning can be.
For example, when you are trying
to aggregate so many times, many
to do aggregation.
So different attributes have
different types of aggregations
that we can think of doing on
that.
So that is one way in which we
can differentiate the world,
differentiate that attributes
and the other way is the type of
operations that are possible on
these attributes.
So that can be another way.
So we will, we will rather look
at attributes as four types
based on these criteria.
And they are like this.
So data first, we divide it into
numerical and categorical.
So now you can see that what is
happening to my where cache.
So the VAD care if it is for
storing an address.
Of of let's say 100 characters.
It is very unlikely that 100
characters you provide and you
give a free flowing freedom to
people to write the address in
different ways.
Somebody starts with house
number.
Sometimes somebody starts with
street names.
Somebody starts with the city
name so, but then whatever name
that you give it is possible to
interpret by some human actor.
So it is unlikely that such data
will be useful for any data
science task.
And coming back just to see any
questions, OK, there are some
raised hands.
I do not know whether that is
for anything to do with the what
we are talking now, uh, or this
is something.
So if we are having a varchar
just for storing some
descriptive elements, we may not
be able to use any of that for
our data science model building.
I hope we are In Sync.
Alright, let me enable the
enable the MIC for you people so
that I'll become even more
confident that we are In Sync.
Alright, so now what we are
saying is that so for data
science purposes, the our own
processes processing.
So we would define the data,
divide the data into 2 broad
categories, one is a numerical
data that can be floating point,
or it is a integer short integer
long integer.
It is a sometimes can be other
types that many of the systems
support and the other one is
categorical.
So categorical can be expressed
in many ways, so it can be
expressed in the form of some
codes.
Whatever be the code so it can
be like many times, you can see
that two letter state code is
used for car registration or a
bike registration.
So it is possibly that can be
one because that uh, that gives
a standardization and then when
vehicle moves from Interstate
traffic, so it is comfortable
for the staff to work with such
numbers.
So it can be any type of
categorical.
So the point is that so
categorical is indicating this.
So even G ZIP codes is
categorical, so it is possible
that I think in India we may be
having up to 1,000,000 PIN
codes, but we will still call
them as category because they
are 1,000,000 distinct values.
Nothing more, nothing less.
So the number doesn't matter but
distinct values.
That makes it nominal so, but
that is not numerical.
I hope that is comfortable with
everybody.
So PIN code is not numerical
even though it is a number, but
Aye.
it is a categorical.
I was about to ask that, Sir.
Numerical values.
We look at it for any bling, the
computations, the computations
can be of the two forms mood of
all operations or or plus minus
operations.
So if it permits only only
differencing.
Then only we can look at the
difference.
Then it is interval so we can
look at both the difference and
ratio.
It is ratio type, so we'll look
at examples.
So I hope that will be clarified
so so you can look at the types
of attributes.
So possibly this helps.
Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, sorry said to interrupt
like in the address of any human
having a mobile number.
It is also falls under the
category will not in the
numerical because we are not
going to perform any numerical
accent there.
Absolutely.
Absolutely right.
Absolutely.
Numerical.
The mobile number itself can be
categorical because mobile
number can serve as a key value
in certain certain databases and
And.
so and we cannot think in terms
of, we cannot say that mobile
number, let's say it is a 2
digit code 94 is closer to 93
then 36.
It doesn't work like so mobile
number is independent and it is
Exactly right.
a key value.
Absolutely you're right.
The numerical data in the
address I don't think is there,
but if the human if I talk about
a person like height like weight
and these things will come as a
number.
Absolutely.
They are numbers and they we can
compare the differences.
Also, we can say that one person
is 2 inches taller than that.
That makes some that gives us
something, so possibly we can we
So all of that, yes.
may be able to use it for some
purpose, right?
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
So I'm not questioning this, so
we have an ordinal and nominal
Right.
route, so grades and shirt size
and color, so somewhat similar
to each.
Say for example in short, size
and color are always similar
characteristics.
How come it comes under
ordinary?
I mean, how do we categorize
this?
No, no.
If you say it is a color of a
cloth color of a cloth cannot be
ordinary, it has to be a
nominal.
It is just a you have a
categorical values, people call
them as categorical variables or
sometimes as nominal variables.
But then when you say the size,
it is ordinal because what you
know is that if a small size is
not fitting, the people will say
go for next which is medium.
Or if the next is large, then
extra large.
So the point is that there is a
there is a ranking associated
with that.
OK.
Are you fine?
Yes. OK. Thank
So I hope these examples are
clear enough to indicate when we
call them as nominal, ordinal,
interval or issues and these are
more for the purpose of
understanding because we are
trying to analyze the data and
discover a pattern.
So we need to know what are the
types of operations that we can
perform and what are the
sensible operations and what are
the nonsense I mean, because
even just because two people
have your mobile number that
differs by only one, it doesn't
mean anything because it's not.
So it has to be treated in a
different way.
But then if two people have a
have a income which is differing
by only small amount, then maybe
you will club them into same
group saying that both of them
are likely to buy a product or
likely to buy likely to do
something.
Some mother in some other terms
where the income matters, so
they can be plugged into the
same group.
So in that sense, the values
matter in some cases and and the
matter in a different way in
other cases.
Here are some more examples, so
I hope it clarifies him even
better.
And at this point, let us keep
the operations aside, though you
may be able to understand some
operations.
So I don't want to go into the
computation of entropy, and so
we will come to that as we go
along.
So.
So I hope the the examples and
the descriptions are clear.
Some of them you will anyway
know what is a geometric mean.
What is a harmonic mean?
What is a?
You mean some of you may know
mean and mode, median and mode.
Uh, so.
So if you want uh, the standard
deviation and mean, I'm sure
people will.
People maybe knowing so.
So what we are saying is the the
type of attributes decide what
is it that we can do so that
decides what is the type of?
What is the contribution that
this attribute can do to them?
Another way to look at the
attributes is discrete or
continuous.
So essentially the continuous is
the ones which are having
represented by floating point
and get discrete can be
represented either by a integer
number saying that for example
you are going to say tall is 1
and short is a medium is too and
short is 3.
That can be a numerical
representation, but discrete is
a limited possible values, and
the binary is a very special
case of discrete.
We only two possible values can
exist.
And there is another type of
attribute which we want to
consider as asymmetric
attribute.
So Assymmetric attributes or,
uh, interesting in the sense
that only non 0 value the two
values are not equally
important.
So asymmetric variables it can
take two possible values.
Only one of the value is
important.
Other value is unimportant.
So for example, let us say a
doctor is examining the patients
and what the doctor did is to
order.
Ordered.
The 12T100 hundred diagnostic
tests, because something, let's
assume they they are the same
for people.
So what is the expectation when
you are performing these hundred
diagnostic tests, so most of
them?
Will be yen loaded with EN.
So suppose there is some.
Why some way?
That is going to become very
significant.
So in fact, the doctor is only
interested because expects that
people in general are healthy.
So if there is a, there is a
symptom that is expressed
through the diagnostic test.
Then they need to do the
diagnosis for that and the
possibly find the suitable
remedy.
So in such cases.
You can see some more examples,
but then this is I thought this
is a stronger example so that
will tell that the attribute is
asymmetric because no has no
value.
And it is the yes, which
differentiates, for example
patient one and patient two when
they're comparing them.
It's essentially most of them
are known, so you can say that
they have 90% similarity, so we
ignore all the nodes that are
common to both and we only
consider wherever the why is
existing for one of the
patients.
Then we say that these two
patients are different to the
sextant, so that is the
characteristic of asymmetric
attributes.
So here is an example I think.
I think it it should be a very
simple example, so I'm also
giving away the answer so you
can see that the attributes
which are nominal ratio and
ordinal.
So one thing which is missing
here is the time stamp where
we'll keep that.
The time stamp is generally
considered as an interval
because only thing that matters
with respect to time is the
difference between the time.
You cannot think of dividing the
time and do anything.
Sir, how ID is nominal.
When can you explain?
Because there are only few
distinct values and you cannot
think of business because it is
numeric, you don't do the
subtraction or addition or
anything like that.
You don't say that the
difference between first record
and 2nd record is only one it it
makes no sense.
So you have to treat that as
each is an individual value,
right?
It is pretty much like one of
your colleagues talked about the
mobile number.
So mobile number because we are
not supposed to do additions and
subtractions on those numbers,
we just need to treat them as an
individual identifiers.
So can we categorize like if it
is in something which identifies
individuality, that's a nominal,
that's OK.
Yeah.
Yes, something.
Yeah.
Nominally, something which is,
it is sometimes even the color
of a person is also a color of a
cloth is also a nominal because
it can have a few distinct
values, and similarly profession
of a person is also nominal.
Yeah, there are.
There are several things which
are nominal where you do not
have a opportunity to make a
comparison and you have to treat
them as a distinct values.
So it need not be completely
identifying value but example
you may have two mobile phones
and may not.
That may not be the key field,
but still it is a.
It is going to be a nominal.
Similarly, Egypt Code will be
nominal, even though it may not
Umm.
be identifying anybody anything.
OK.
An ordinary, something that
represents this property of
that.
The way there is a grading.
So for example, in one
organization there is a
Grading.
designation which is a ranking
saying that you join as
assistant engineer, then you
become engineer, then a senior
engineer, junior manager, senior
manager and all that.
So you know that there is a
sequence, so it is.
So you know that manager and
senior manager are far closer in
their experience or whatever
compared to senior manager in
distant so that you call that as
an ordinal variable because
there is a differentiation order
order both all of them are
nominal in their values.
But then there is a ranking with
respect to those values.
So how can gender be nominal,
Sir?
We can't.
We can use it to do some
analysis, right?
So how can it be nominal?
No, what else it can it can be.
What else do you think it will?
It will be.
I'm sorry if the point is that
it is a.
See, we are not saying that it
is just differentiating one of
the attributes of the people.
Is it known?
It is just one attribute of the
person, or what else it can be,
I mean.
Then age can also be nominal,
right?
No, no.
Yeah, age is the The thing is
that you can say that the person
with ten years experience is
having double the experience of
the person with five years
experience or the person with 50
years Live it for double the
time that 25 year old person
lived on the earth.
So there is also a ratio that
you can do, right?
No, I don't think I'm following
this.
So why should I?
So maybe they're the ratio.
Gender can also be defined,
maybe, or she might be referring
to that by like.
We can say this number these
many number of mails with
Yeah.
respect to these number first
females.
No, no, no, no.
We are not talking about that.
I aggregates we are talking
about individual records.
OK.
We are talking about individual
records and record values and
what you can do with those
values.
So in case of things like age or
height, we are saying that they
also have an element of.
We can make a comparison though
height.
You can say how you can divide
and all that place, but you can
there is something like we can
say this is twice the long as
that.
So humans, we don't do.
But then suppose we are
measuring some bar.
We can say that someone bar is
twice the length of the other.
Another bar.
Oh yes.
Is that still uncomfortable?
Some for someone.
I don't know who was there
talking about the age and
gender.
Well, like.
Yeah, I was talking when I just
need to.
I'll redo through the video once
again.
OK, OK.
No problem.
So so yeah, this because Yage
allows us to do computations.
So so the computations.
So you agree that it is at least
interval right, Mr Shamshad you
Yeah, yeah.
agree that at least it has
interval?
It is numeric and it allows you
to do some calculations and but
Yeah.
in gender you can only do an
identification.
Either it is male or female,
nothing more, right?
So it is like pretty much like a
color.
You can identify the color of
the car is black or red.
You cannot do anything else with
that, but do you agree with that
Yeah.
or do you still it is still
discomforting, so so the point
is and then with the age you can
do the computations and then the
age.
We are saying that it is ratio
because we can also think in
terms of double and triple and
possibly but then in general
maybe we don't do that.
But this also permits because it
starts with a G08A newborn has
age of 0 and then it goes all
the way and then we can do a
ratio if we wish.
But with respect to time, you
cannot do a ratio.
So you can you have to stick to
interval.
Is this still some discomfort?
Some one person raised hand.
I don't know whether for this
one or something else.
One person has reason.
With everything thing that
labels are record right would be
nominal.
Labels are nominal always right?
That is correct, yes.
To male or female labels are
record, so it would be nominal
No, no.
basically.
Male and female are not labels
because these are see yes.
So in that sense, yeah, it is
giving a characteristic.
So it is a kind of yeah, you can
possibly say.
So you are saying that yes, so
that word is they are becoming
nominal, yes.
I don't know whether people will
agree if they say that you're
labeling someone as a male or
female, so that's why I I I
don't want to get into that.
But you you be what we are
saying is that it is a
Yeah, you can send the data in
the.
characteristic that we can
simply say yes, it is.
It takes 2 possible values, but
we do cannot perform any
operations like ordinal saying
that one is let one level and
other is that we cannot do and
we cannot do any numeric
operations so it is coming into.
And hope everybody's
comfortable.
So liquidly the relation to one
record and for that one record
what it is it in that's going to
determine what it is?
What?
What kind of attribute it?
Hi, Mr Rajesh, are you answering
is there a question I'm little.
No, no, there's no question is
this trying to somehow?
You OK?
You're trying to explain.
OK. OK.
Thank you.
OK.
So we'll proceed further.
Uh, I said.
Just want to little
clarification like we can divide
the two groups of the.
If I divide in the two groups of
male or female, then we can
decide that which either female
get the perform better because
the great maybe that all of the
girls are passed female past but
not all the male paths.
Yes.
So we can here we do the
operations like group of females
having performed better than a
male.
So this type of performance can
be NBA young.
You're set operation.
We can perform had something.
See Mr Vishal.
Mr Vishal, you can perform many
operations so, but then yes, so
suddenly that can be one
possibility, for example.
So in the job selection or in
the university ranking something
here you can always analyze and
you can say that there is a.
Based on this, you can also say
something more like for example
people who are coming with
certain background in or doing
better than the others.
So it is becoming another
attribute just like gender.
So you're saying that, OK,
people who are coming with a
Hope.
this type of job description not
doing better or people coming
with this type of degree or
doing better.
So there can be many parameters
based on which you can analyze.
But.
So all of them are racially the
same way we are putting them in
the same way I think you are
just giving one more example,
right?
Yeah.
OK, alright.
Yeah.
OK.
So we'll proceed further.
So I think this example is done
and then we can also look at
discrete and continuous in a
similar way.
You can see that the age is
continuous and then grade is a
discrete, but then ordinal and
then similarly percentage of
marks is continuous and all
others are discrete.
So now, now we will look at
types of data sets.
Not much to talk about with
this.
We did discuss about this in the
last class.
So so we are just elaborating a
little further saying that the
data type can be structured or
unstructured, but sometimes we
can have something in between
which is semi structured.
We can also have something
called a quasi structured, so
structured.
I think it requires no big
explanation and this is referred
to very often.
The relational RDBMS data.
So you typically have sometimes
what is known as a master data
or which changes very little, or
you can have it transaction
data.
So which is which refers to
master data and also
incorporates the recent events
and keeps getting flushed
knowing then so so that is
referring to the structured data
semi structured data is typical
JSON Data where or XML data
where you have a label and data
and then we are talking about
the quasi structured data is
some people put this some people
bring in some authors bring in
So what we are talking about is
a textual data which can have
erratic formats which we get
from different and then we need
to put in some effort to put it
into some structure so and then
unstructured data.
These are data with bit no
inherent structure.
So so this this nomenclature is
again, possibly different
authors tend to use a slightly
different nomenclatures.
So what is well known is
structured, unstructured and
then semi structured for a long
time the convention has been
SSML XML and Jason.
Alright, so we will look at
there are many sources of data
sets and these are just a few
examples.
But then you find many, many
sources.
In fact, there are many
governments which are posting
their data and and encouraging
their citizens to analyze the
data, and this is a classic
source which is the University
of California at Irvine for a
long time they have been
collecting and posting the data
and for a long time people have
been using this for learning
data science.
And they have.
They have a huge datasets that
and they also classify saying
that this data set is good for
learning unsupervised machine
learning or clustering or so.
Various types of purposes for
which you can use that data set
and Kaggle.
You may all have heard, and that
is they.
There is a mini data scientists
come together to share knowledge
and organize competitions kind
of things, and then Canada is 1
it one which seems to have a lot
of data that they share and but
then there are many other
countries also with share a lot
of data that they have which
people can use for for their
analysis and but then there are
many other sources.
These are just a, just some
limited examples and then there
can be private data where there
are several constraints are
there with respect to using them
for public analysis.
Then record data we have already
seen.
What is the record data then?
We are talking about data
metrics.
Data matrix is we are typically
talking about number of rows and
the number of columns and in
fact it's the same data can be
expressed in a in a a
homogeneous way.
So so that is why we call it.
So in fact, typically people
call the data matrix when
they're all numbers, so that is
the tendency to for people to
refer.
But then this is again another
term because you can as well
call this as Yum Records, then a
document data.
So this is a tricky thing.
So how to represent a document?
So first question, we need to
answer is how to represent it
on.
In the files.
In a file, no, no, no.
File is a file.
Maybe you are saying how you
store the data, right?
Most likely a Jason.
In the form of a Jason, you are
saying.
OK, OK, see.
But the Jason's purpose is
Jason.
When you say, suppose that this
is representing some speech
Moody has given in a Prime,
Minister has given on
Independence Day so that you can
get it as a document.
So now you are saying that you
will represent that in a JSON
better.
I don't think so.
Does it?
Is there any point that you want
to make?
And Mr Manoj, would you say
something?
Of.
Yeah.
As a key value pair.
Is it like a?
Key value payments, but then key
value sees.
Always that what is the
keywords?
First you need to identify the
words right?
The important words, that is
what you are saying is that what
Mr Manoj, you want to say, you
need to identify important words
and look at the whether they're
occurring or not.
Is it correct?
Yeah. Yeah.
How many times is 3 occurring?
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
OK.
So that is essentially we are
saying that is a model that is
referred as a bag of words
model.
So.
So The thing is that we know a
sentence makes sense only if we
look at the sequence of the
sentence.
Once you change the sequence of
the sentence, the meaning
changes or the meaning is
completely lost or or or the
meaning can become exact
opposite, because for example
you change the position of, not
the meaning of the word sentence
will change, but then the bag of
words does not consider the
meaning bag of words.
Simply looks at the words and
the frequency in which, so this
is 1 model which is the simplest
possible model to represent a
document and then perform some
analysis.
Because this is we got a, we got
a matrix and obviously we can
start performing many
mathematical operations and we
can try to make some sense.
For example, you can say that
two documents are similar if
they have the same words which
are repeating very often, so
that can be one operation.
So.
So the point is that depending
on the data, so we need to think
in terms of how to represent so.
So the document we may spend A
at some point little later about
understanding how to create a
meaningful structures out of the
document.
But then I hope this explains
well enough saying that one
simplest representation is to
identify the keywords as one of
you.
One of you also pointed out the
same thing before.
Before even I mentioned it so,
so that can be one approach, but
there can be more approaches
that we will see later.
So then we can have a
transaction data so that we can
simply represent as a list of
items.
But we need to be clear that
this list of items we are taking
the Market Basket example for
easy understanding, but you can
also have examples like like
this.
Young.
Rich.
And then possibly.
Educated.
And and then possibly something
more or we can say we can go
into the American.
So without controversy, we can
use that a Democrat.
And then similarly we can say
another person is senior citizen
and then the person is, let's
say middle income.
Middle income I'm I'm trying to
put something I'm like pen
middle income and then let's say
let's say educated and then
Republican.
So now even when you create a
list of this, you can still do
association analysis.
So Market Basket example is easy
to understand, but you can
always say that young people
tend to be rich or rich.
People tend to be Democrats, so
on and so forth.
So there is there are so many
other problems that patterns
that you can discover.
OK.
And then graph data I do not
think I need to explain so the
web is a graph where each
document is linked to many other
documents and similarly you can
have a graphs to represent the
roadways railway networks, the
communication networks and a lot
of things and social media which
is offering a lot of networks
like LinkedIn or Facebook.
So we may want to analyze such
data and and that is just to say
that that is another variety of
data we have and then order
data.
We have already seen that we can
find sequential patterns from
the order later and we may have
an order date of the form of
genomic sequence.
So again, from there we can find
the sequential patterns, but
then how we use the pattern and
how to really how to make sense
out of the pattern that that's
way beyond, but then we can
still find a pattern saying that
somebody is saying that there
are two gene sequences I got and
then how frequently I find that
this pattern so so they can look
at this sequence saying that
because the sequence is
important.
So The thing is that you will
find only four types of
alphabets repeating, but then
the sequence is making a
difference.
So.
So we can say that this is also
one of the sequential problems.
Audio it can be considered
sequential, but more often it is
a.
It is a more of a time series
and what you can see is that you
are possibly taking the
sampling.
You're doing the sampling at
regular intervals because audio
we need to consider as a
continuous data, but then, but
then we we stick with setting
frequent no set in a frequency
of sampling and then take the
data and then we start
processing.
And then video or sorry image
image, we can take it as A2
dimensional data.
Sport, black and white or Gray
images, and then we can treat
that as a 3 dimensional data.
So or three sets of two
dimensional data for the purpose
of color images.
Because we store red, green,
blue independently for color
images for black and white, we
simply store pixel Gray level.
And now the question will be
that how are we going to work
with this type of data?
So so we we may, it is just to
as a some of you may already
know, nowadays we are working
with the neural networks which
have got a which have the
ability to take large number of
inputs.
Suppose that you somehow have
got a image which is of this
size 100 by 100 pixels.
So there are, it is not at all
difficult to design or a neural
network which takes 10,000
inputs and we start processing
them with multiple layers.
So the here what is happening is
that that 10,800 by 100 emails
became a U uni dimensional
vector of 10,000 size and we are
working but then we can also
find the patterns using other
mechanisms.
Uh and then start working with
the patterns that we discovered.
In fact, many times those
patterns are what we do is we do
some type of operations.
They are referred if some of you
are familiar called convolution,
whereby identify the local
patterns of the adjacent pixels
and thereby did they look for
the features.
So so there are ways in which
people have found ways.
But then but then after
converting them, not keeping it
as image as it is, but then
converting it into some
structured data.
Though it is referred as an
unstructured data in almost all
textbooks, but then people found
ways to convert it into create
some structure and then discover
the pack.
Now let us look at the topic of
for data quality.
It's a.
It's actually a very big topic.
A lot of people have published a
lot of articles on quality
because quality is not such an
easy thing to define though
though it is something which we
we all want, it is not easy to
define.
So we let us look at some way in
which we can define data
quality.
So our authors are putting it in
terms of accuracy, completeness,
consistency, timeliness,
believability, interpretability.
So.
So the point is that data
quality can be these are the
causes.
Some of the causes.
Off back quality or look
quality.
But there can be many moods, so
The thing is that we have a one
of the big problems in modeling
for any of the task is to
identify which attribute is
relevant.
So that is not not not listed in
any of the issues, but if you
are unable to identify the
relevant data, your model can
never be good.
The data quality like orphan
data in case of relational data
only right Harpending otherwise.
It can be.
See the orphan data is something
which we cannot have a reference
bare by.
We can comment on that data so
so something.
Yeah, that.
But it is only in the case of
relational database, not not in
the case of irrigation means.
Yeah.
Well, you can.
You can say that if it is, if it
is not a structured data, how
can you think in terms of a
parent or a hierarchy 3 to fine?
Jackie.
So there is no connecting master
data, so fine, fine.
I'll.
I'll take it.
It is a structured data right
here, but we also need to
understand today there are no
there are many no SQL databases.
They say that they are not
relational, but a lot of data
that they store has some
structure but different types of
structures from the different
based on the different types of
the no SQL databases.
So they may also have orphan
data in the sense that the
missing graphical link or
missing uh is some associations
that are missing between the
records or or tuples.
So several things can happen so,
but then I'll take it.
I'll take it that yes, if it
isn't.
If the structure is missing
then.
Any any comments on data quality
or fine?
So we'll proceed further.
So some of the some more thing
is noise and outliers.
So the noise is a something
which comes from video sources.
So for example, you go to a
shopping a some shop and then
when you buy a product, uh, they
ask for maybe maybe in some
places they want to keep a track
of their customer information.
So they want you to put the data
on the me ask you for some data.
So let's say you give a #34 the
person types in as 43, so it is
a noise.
It is an error.
It is pretty random because the
person may be typing for 99
people correctly for one person.
They make the person may be
typing wrongly, so there can be
many varied sources, so it is a
highly unpredictable type of
error that we call as noise.
We do not know how to get rid of
noise, so the noise is something
that we don't know.
It is always negative.
Noise has always a negative
influence.
On our process.
So but then it is possible that
sometimes there is a data which
is significantly deviating from
the other data, so that may be
very useful sometimes.
But that may be there are there
are sometimes, as we discussed
so out, clear analysis is a task
by itself because outliers are.
So interesting in set I'm cases
there are certain business
problems for which outliers are
very import.
Then inaccurate data.
Again, the inaccurate data can
be caused by various reasons, so
Sorry.
it's again inaccuracy can be
instrumentation, but it can also
be a noise.
Sorry to interrupt, but in the
previous slide one I have a one
question.
In the previous slide input.
Yes, OK.
OK, I I go to the previous
slide.
Just give me one minute.
Yeah.
So in coding of the data is also
the quality of the issue.
But in coding isn't something
system related.
Things not the collection of the
data.
That is true, but then when we
have data from multiple sources
and they somehow chosen to
encode it in different way, that
can become a quality issue.
But, but that is true as long as
you know the encoding.
You should be able to decode.
Uh umm?
Any example Sir?
No encoding.
For example, simple thing is
that you have two offices where
they are following a different
conventions for putting the
address or putting something so
or it may be sometimes interbank
transaction so they put the
things in a different format or
different structure.
So somebody is putting the date
of birth and somebody is putting
it day.
Is that itself can be a
difference or somebody is using
for example the two three types
of products that they have
small, medium, large.
Let's say they're coding.
That has 123 other people are
putting it as 321.
Umm.
Anything.
I mean any any way where you
have a different encoding it
becomes a problem, but then
that's not a big issue.
OK.
So as you said, if you are able
to get the codes correct, but
then sometimes you you also have
the associated problems.
So suppose that there are dates
which are coming from the
multiple sources you're now you
cannot be sure that are they
following the same conventional
put the writing the date in DMY
also.
OK, we'll get like a we can give
the example of shared having a
large, medium and short, but
also that 4236 and 44 because
two way of representation of the
same set.
Yeah, yeah, that is also
possible because one company may
call short is 32, but another
may call up to 34, right?
So that is always possible here.
So there is nothing like nothing
like ours.
Expertise is involved.
All we know is that when we get
data from multiple sources,
there can be errors.
OK.
Thanks Sir.
Alright, so we are talking about
noise outliers, inaccurate data
and inconsistent data. Right.
And let us take an example to
see the data quality issues.
I'm sure you will be able to
find many of them here, right?
So if somebody wants to read out
any issue that they found.
Percentage issue well.
Here for me.
That way both of both.
Date formats.
Wait for me.
This missing data person?
Missing data.
Miss missing data.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely yes, it is 175.
Percentage percentage.
But Centage is incorrect.
Percentage is 175.
That's it.
Yes, yes, straight absolutely
yes.
Present day 125.
Yeah, 175 could be outlier data
maybe.
And duplicate data as well.
ID's.
Duplicate data is there.
Uh.
Missing ID duplicated.
Because.
Yeah.
So so there is.
Yeah, I think you, I think we
found almost everything.
Different.
So so let me go and give the
answer also, because you found
already all the values.
So you can see that because of
the date of birth and days, it
is easy to recognize that
something is inconsistent.
So, but the format of age, date
of birth is also inconsistent
and sometimes the age and date
of birth are not matching.
So essentially so that gives
rise to another problem.
Uh, Sir?
I just one thing.
So, uh, like when we observe
such kind of inconsistent data.
So do we follow any compensating
functionality or structure to
handle or to operate on such an
inconsistent datas?
Or do we have certain kind of
algorithm of modeling of such
See, there are many tools which
which help you identify the
data? Uh.
problems in the data and all you
all you have to do is that
because there are so many ETL
tools that that are there in the
market, so sometimes they call
them and sells as ELT tools.
Sometimes they call them as ETL
tools.
So essentially they do the they
take the data and then do the
checks that you propose.
Saying that this has to follow
this rule then so you can give
OK.
some set and rules.
So, so whereby they can validate
and give you all their
observations.
OK. OK.
So from the observation
perspective, we have tools but
like if you want to have propose
some solution over that
inconsistent data so that it
becomes.
Yeah.
If you say that you want to
replace something, for example
default value for certain field
that you want to put wherever it
Yeah.
is missing.
Yeah, it will do that.
No.
It will do.
OK.
OK, OK. Got it.
Thank you.
Alright, so now let us go into
data model.
So what I will do is we have 10
minutes, so I'll just see
whether a data model we can
discuss.
I'm just waiting for a few
seconds to see if if everything
is clear, so feel free to bring
up.
Uh, is this the last class for
you today or I think this is the
4th last class for you.
Right.
OK. So.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
OK, OK.
So I don't have a constraint
that I have to close it at 5:50,
is that is that a fair
expectation? No.
OK.
And.
Yes.
Yeah, like there's too much of
download download today, Sir.
Alright.
Can we do it next?
Yeah.
Yeah, that.
Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
That's why I'm I'm giving a I'm
giving you a break for a few
No.
seconds just to think about
anything that we discussed so
far is that leaving you confused
or or I can proceed little
further.
I have 10 minutes about so we
can.
Anyway, we'll proceed if there
are no questions.
OK, we'll proceed.
So now let us look at what to do
with a model.
So this is taken from the
reference book, the Art of Data
Science.
So this is a the entire book is
available at the URL.
So now you can see that the data
science is not a linear process.
It is not even simply iterative
process.
So what they say is that at
every stage there is an
iteration, not.
It's not an iteration at the
entire cycle, so so the point
that the that the author is
trying to convey is that.
So you start with a data, but
you cannot be sure that that is
the correct data.
That data quality is good.
The data is relevant and and so
on, and then you come and you
say that you want to find
certain pattern, so you need to
see whether is that the
important pattern or is that a
useful pattern?
Or is that the pattern that is
the business is really looking
for order?
Or is it that something that the
business never asked, but you
think that it is useful and you
want to go back and check?
Do you want to do you like this
type of packet and at every
point there is this level of
iteration?
What?
That what he's saying.
What they are saying is that
every place there is something
that you want to go back and
keep performing.
So so this is what the art of
data science they are saying.
So they are looking at things as
as a highly nonlinear and every
place there is some learning and
there is a refinement.
Not much, and now we are going
into what is a statistical
model.
So that is to help understand a
generalization of the nature of
data science.
But first thing you want to do
is that we get a data, we get
data.
Suppose that I got a data saying
that I am teaching uh it class
for BITS third year students.
I got data of those those
people.
First thing I got is age.
They age is 191820211918.
So what can I do with this?
So I know that the age is very
strongly range bound, right?
So I can think saying that I can
comfortably say that most of my
all my students are around 19
years of age, right?
So that is something I'm able to
do so I can generate a
statistic.
So first thing that I can do is
that whenever I have a a data, I
can think in terms of.
Can I summarize the data?
I can summarize the data using
some of the metrics so.
And the Demi help.
So now, now what we are saying
is that that is possibly going
to help us.
And but then when we when we
impose saying that this is the
structure.
So I'm saying that my students
are of the age 19, my BITS third
year students are of the age 19.
So now now the question that
comes up is that.
Is this an accurate expectation?
So this is a very simple data
element, but then you can have a
multidimensional data elements.
So even there you may want to
recognize the patterns.
So now what?
Why is it important?
Because sometimes we may want to
work with the samples.
OK.
And and we may also want to know
some.
Ranges so that may help us in
another way, and it may help us
generate saying that we say, OK,
19 years means is a teenager and
we can expect certain
characteristics associated with
that.
Now let us see uh, we are almost
running out, but we will.
We will simply look at this
example and and maybe this
example suppose that I we have
small survey on 20 people and
the question that we are asking
is how much they are going to
spend on a product and the
response is this.
Now the question is, so I hope
we talked.
I think we talked about in the
last class about election
results because there are so
many agencies who are trying to
work and they keep on trying to
predict.
I keep getting calls saying.
Can you share with us who did
you vote for?
Kind, but then they're not
obviously calling to the entire
country.
They are only calling to a
randomly to some numbers some
numbers, and then they're trying
to get their answers and then
they're trying to see whether
they they'll be able to predict.
So in that case, the survey of
20 people is good or not.
Again, you need to judge it is
not.
It is.
There is no rule saying that 20
is good enough sample, but but
then OK let us say we got the 20
elements and then we got the
data and then we have computed
some some statistics mean and
standard deviation and then I
hope for everybody knows what is
in normal distribution.
So we can say that the mean is
is available in standard
deviation is available.
I can make a plot of normal
distribution and can I say that
this normal distribution is
representing what people are
willing to pay for my product?
What do you say?
What do you notice?
And you have any comment?
Every Sprint is around $17.00.
Uh.
Is is that a fair distribution?
But.
The standard, the normal
distribution that we have put,
does it seem to be fair?
Both.
Most of the people are ready to
pay level level dollar ten point
something the average price is
17 point something.
See average is we are matching
the average.
We are trying to match the
standard deviation, but when we
make this plot, is it looking
fair?
Fair, fair representation of our
data.
Another.
No.
So I think there's too much
deviation.
No, you're not.
No, the accesses need to be
inverted.
It is not.
The density on the pop prices
need to be inverted so that.
Lots of.
There are a lot of extreme
cases.
Yes.
Really, the clients are low.
Yeah.
So so that is what so so do you
see any problems when we are
looking at this so because what
we have got is you already even
if you there is no need to
remember this, so this is the
data that we have and then this
is approximate histogram.
Something.
And then when we converted, when
we set that, OK, many times
people represent that data is
normal distribution and then
that that they solve some
modeling problems using that and
we wanted to do that.
So what is the problem that we
are seeing?
That is not fitting into normal
distribution.
Absolutely right.
Data is not fitting into normal
distribution.
What are the reasons that you
see here what is the deviations
that you see here?
25 is an outlier.
Yes, 25 is way off, so that is A
and and the other thing is that
it is also allowing a negative
price because the normal
distribution takes the mean and
tries to fit it along with a
standard deviation.
So it is going saying that minus
10 is fine.
But then in this case, who is
going to give a product for a
negative price?
So it is always positive, but
then this is unable to capture
that.
So.
So what we are seeing is that we
have so many times data and then
sometimes we have to model the
data because our algorithm
demands certain model and then
thereby it is going to create a
pattern.
But the model that we find is
not always we we have to be
careful because we may not
always get the correct model.
So if we have, so if we take
this model and then we try to
generate histogram, this will
look like this.
But this histogram is no where
close to the sampling that we
had done survey.
We had done this survey is way
different from the histogram
which matches this normal
representation.
So what that means is that we
need to look for possibly some
alternate representation.
So one alternate representation
we can think of is a gamma
distribution.
So a gamma distribution may
better fit in with this data.
So for the simple reason that
gamma distribution can take
parameters that shape the curve.
And and then let us see how the
gamma distribution.
Do I have it?
Don't have it.
Just give me.
K.
Maybe I'll I'll.
Yeah, like this is.
It's not.
Are we going to get that for the
direct standard deviations from
the government institutions?
Explanations because we have the
new league.
Ohh.
Gonna standard deviation.
OK.
OK, you are saying standard
deviation definition.
Nobody has discussed till now,
right, Mr Mahindra is, is that
Yeah, yeah, yes.
the question?
Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
We will, we will be discussing
that I I had I I had assumed
that OK, some people will know
and even when for others don't
know I had already given a
disclaimer saying that you don't
need to.
We will come to those
definitions as we come along, so
OK.
that is fine.
So all we are saying is that
standard deviation is indication
of how much variance that is
existing.
So for example, let me put to
explain the standard deviation.
Let me put two samples, so let
me let me put this I'm
overrunning the time I.
Maybe I'm going to close it
pretty soon.
So suppose that there is an
organization, one where the
employee ages are.
252629 and 33.
OK.
Then the organization two, which
has got employees which is let
me put 29 and 20 and 38.
So in both these organizations,
the mean age of the employees is
same, but the differentiation is
the spread of the ages.
Mr Mahindra Reddy does it
explain so that is a standard
deviation measure.
So we will give the formula but,
but this model example should
tell you that this has a higher
deviation compared to this.
It's right.
But yeah, so that that means the
difference between the I mean
Yeah, so this is what we will.
We will exact formula, but it's
not a big.
distance between the min and Max
of the range.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Right, absolutely.
So so go right.
The Min Max difference will be
widely varying for datasets
which have got a high standard
deviation compared to which have
the low standard deviation.
So code question right?
Why not average right?
Instead of a median here.
Ah, OK, average and median is a
very interesting thing.
The median indicates how many
people are below and how many
people are able.
So let me let me put.
Let me put another example where
how the suppose that I got
another organization.
Let me put the age each again.
I'm putting some more people so
so that it is easy for me to
explain.
And they also have a a centrally
a part time or or a consultant
who is working and they treat
that person as an employee.
They hide that person for a
special region and that person's
age is 67.
So now you compute the mean of
this.
So what will be the mean about
40, right?
And what will be the median?
Median is 20 and which is more
reasonable.
So this is this is you make all
this agent out clear the median
can withstand outliers better
than the mean.
Or does that answer your
question?
OK.
So that is a that again I think
we will hopefully we will get,
we'll get, we'll have an
opportunity to discuss that when
we discuss these statistics
little later in preprocessing.
Are we fine now till now?
What we discussed is clear.
So so I will close the session
and next class we will do a
quick review of data model and
then we'll proceed further.
Yes, Sir.
Any questions?
So all we are saying is that
data model, this model is better
Hello, very good.
I'm gonna go out.
than this model.
So we have also to make choice
of model so that we are going to
get better results with respect
to our data science task.
OK.
Mr Mahindra, were you trying to
say something?
Funnel and look.
OK.
Any anyone has any question or
observation OK if there are no
questions so I'm going to close
the session.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sir.
Hey, thank you so much.
Thank you, Sir.
I I guess so.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you so.
Thank you, Sir. Yeah.
And then.
Thank you.
Alright.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.
So that's the reason.
Yeah, Mr SUMIT Kumar, there is
nothing like we will, we will
Thank you, Sir.
come to these definitions little
later.
Again, standard deviation
compute and all that.
Thank you, Sir.
So.
So whatever is required for our
course, we will cover.
So don't worry about that.
Is there any way you can get
this type of expression through
the example in the real time for
the big three days?
Hi, Mr Mahindra not can you
repeat the question it was
coming with a lot of noise to
me.
So can you repeat it?
OK, I don't see you get any.
I mean, you get, you get these
type of explanation within the
real time examples.
So on which scenarios is that of
things quickly going to be
helpful so that it will be?
OK, you are saying when when do
you use the mean and when do you
use median?
So can I explain that is it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah.
Not only for those two, maybe
for any other any other like
Yeah, we will.
We will explain that really.
standard deviation or the
government discussion, so in
Yes, yes, yes.
real.
See, The thing is that the
standard deviation is used in
almost every statistic.
People put some standard
deviation because that is going
to give an indication of the
distribution of the data.
So standard deviation is
straight away going to tell you
that when standard deviation is
different.
So suppose that there are two
organizations with millions of
products.
So now suppose somebody is
selling products bit the this
type of distribution and another
is selling products with this
distribution.
This has a low deviation.
This is the high deviation.
So this is what it is telling.
Yeah.
So, Mr Mahindra, this is that
clear, so both of them may be
making the same amount of
turnover, but then you can know
you can make out and how that
helps is a really a domain
Which one is better?
related issue.
Somebody is working with a low
deviation type of product and
somebody is having a product
with high deviation.
So somebody is selling a car
with a price range from 5,00,000
to 30,00,000.
Another person is selling most
of the products which are
between 15 to 18,00,000.
So how does it make a
difference?
So they can depend where widely
depending on the domain
situations, but then we can make
that observation based on
Yeah.
standard deviation.
Got it under Amit, since for
this course statistics is the
base, so are we going to get in
December for the statistics
sports also?
Yeah.
Yeah, a little bit of a disc,
whatever statistics related
requirements are there, we will
cover that.
So they we don't require really
very major.
Understanding, but wherever the
little bit is required, how to
define a mean?
How to define a median?
How to define a mode?
How to define define all that we
are going to discuss that we are
going to discuss.
OK, so is this the subject is
entirely theoretical level even
in laptop, but anything can be
there.
Now you have to help me
understand what is theory.
What is practice?
So what are we doing till now?
No, haven't got understanding
the basic concepts of the
things.
Dokey.
So supposed to suppose that I
asked you what is the mean age
That doesn't severely gives me
but.
of some set of data.
So do you call that as a theory
or practice or I don't know what
is?
So you want to learn Python or
or or or?
Is that what you are saying or
you are so you have something
Yeah.
else in mind?
No, that one only.
OK the how to implement that
using given a data.
So in this seven one, are we
going to get that into the?
How to do that?
Yeah.
Yeah, we will.
We will come to that.
So hopefully in we will have
some webinars.
So where we will give you some
introduction to using Python for
solving some of these problems?
Yes, we will come there.
OK.
Next.
Alright, so I think I stopped
recording right?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I stopped recording.
OK, so the last few minutes what
we talked is not recorded also.
OK, fine.
I'll I think we'll close the
session, so there are no
questions that I'm hearing.
My grandson Michael.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.